ist nicht davon auszugehen dass dieser
Ibrahim a auch nach dieser Tat
abgeschoben wird der wird hier bleiben
ja aber nach dieser Zeit wenn er hier
bleibt würde Interesse seines Lebens im
Gefängnis zu bringen und nicht und oder
in der psychiatischen Anstalt ich weiß
nicht aber nicht vielleicht tatsächlich
geistig verwirrt und gestört ist aber er
wird das kann man sicher sagen nicht nur
er als jemanden Migrationshintergrund
sondern auch jeder Deutsche Straftäter
dieser Art würde den Rest seines Lebens
im Gefängnis verbringen und nicht mehr
auf die Allgemeinheit losgelassen andere
Länder treffen Abkommen beispielsweise
Dänemark mit Ruanda und führt Straftäter
dorthin dann abschiebt sie ab wäre das
ein Weg für Deutschland solche Abkommen
zu schließen es ist immer gut Abkommen
zu schließen beispielsweise mit Marokko
oder Tunesien oder Libyen ähm selbst
wenn es teurer wäre es wäre sinnvoll
Staatsangehörige aus diesen Ländern
zurückzubringen wenn Sie bei uns Strafe
nicht geworden sind denn eins muss man
sagen die europäische Menschen kommen
weil Menschenrechtskonvention und auch
unsere Vereinbarungen sind zwar ein
recht aller vor die zu uns kommen auf
einer silverfahren oder bei Flüchtlingen
auf und zu werden aber dieses Recht
erlischt auch nach der Europäischen
Menschenrechtskonvention wenn diese
Persönlichkeiten eine Gefahr für die
öffentliche Sicherheit und Ordnung
darstellen und bei Straftätern dieser
Kategorie mit
körperverletzungshandlungen und Todes
Handlungen ist das sicherlich der Fall
insofern müssen wir konsequenter sein
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob das
dänische Modell Bestand haben wird
innerhalb der Europäischen Union aber
sollte es bestand haben wäre das für
mich Orientierungspunkt das heißt sie
können sich vorstellen jemanden der in
dem Fall ja Staatenloser palästinser im
gar kein Staat hat in den er zurück
abgeschoben werden könnte dass man ein
Abkommen mit einem in diesem Fall von
Dänemark wäre das seine afrikanischer
Staat Ruanda ein Abkommen trifft und den
Straftäter dorthin abschiebt ja es kommt
nicht darauf an dass jemand eine
Staatsangehörigkeit das sondern der
Signatur der Domizil starten muss auch
bereit sein
wir müssen auch entsprechen
den Libanon schließen damit die Staaten
bereit wären ihre Staatsbürger auch
selbst wieder aufzunehmen denn wenn die
auf dem Flughafen sagen der kann wieder
zurückfliegen dann müssen wir wieder mit
nach Hause nehmen also insofern wäre das
eine Möglichkeit wenn wir einen Staat
finden der sagt wir sind bereit die
entsprechende Persönlichkeiten
aufzunehmen und wir garantieren können
dass die einigermaßen menschenwürdig
dort auch leben können dann wünschen sie
dir nicht den Wege sie können jetzt
anfangen zu suchen nach diesen Staaten
sie stellen jetzt in der Bundesregierung
den sozusagen abschiebe-beauftragten mit
Joachim stammt der fängt jetzt in Kürze
mit seinem neuen Job an das heißt er
wird suchen nach diesen Staaten die
Frage müssen sie auch im Stamm stellen
aber ich kann nur feststellen als er in
Nordrhein-Westfalen dafür zuständig war
war es das Bundesland mit den meisten
Abschiebungen von auffällig gewordenen
Personen und insofern wenn ich da
optimistisch dass wenn einer ist
überhaupt auf die Reihe kriegt deswegen
haben sie sein wird zuletzt sind von
300.000 ausreisepflichtigen in
Deutschland zwei Prozent in einem halben
Jahr abgeschoben worden was wäre so eine
Zielmarke für ihn
die ziehenmarke muss dann das alle die
die kein Aufenthaltsrecht haben bei uns
auch das Land wieder verlassen müssen
und das zwangsweise auch durchgesetzt
werden kann das ist das Ziel und wissen
wir aus Erfahrung das war der eine 100%
Quote nicht erreichen würden aber es
wäre schon Schulen schön wenn wir mehr
als die Hälfte in absehbarer Zeit wieder
aus dem Land herausbringen können eine
weil noch einmal Menschen die bei uns
sich an die Rechtsordnung nicht halten
wollen das dezidiert auch immer gebracht
haben durch ihre Taten haben tatsächlich
auch kein Blei und vorbei Recht das sind
wir auch den anderen Menschen die aus
anderen Stellen zu uns kommen schuldig
damit nicht alle über einen Kamm
geschert werden und dann das Problem
entsteht dass Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund diskretiert wird
wir haben in diesen Tagen über einen
Fall berichtet von einem Afghanen auch
der war ja möglicherweise für die
Geschichte der vergangenen Jahre so
typisch ein Straftäter der in
Deutschland seine Straftat begangen hat
eine schwere Vergewaltigung er wurde
daraufhin bestraft er wurde daraufhin
auch abgeschoben nach Afghanistan
urplötzlich tauchte der wieder auf weil
er über die Schweiz nichts mit der
Straßenbahn einfach
rübergefahren ist wieder über die Grenze
nach Deutschland und dort durch einen
Zufall letztlich aufgegriffen wurde
durch baden-württembergische
Polizeibeamte jetzt sitzt er wieder im
Gefängnis aber es ist auch klar der wird
nie wieder abgeschoben weil wir im
Moment nach Afghanistan nicht abschieben
ein Mann der eigentlich dort sein müsste
der abgeschoben werden durfte den dürfen
wir jetzt nicht zurückschieben das ist
doch irre gut auch da muss man sagen wir
haben ihn abgeschoben wir in der
Situation als die Taliban noch nicht die
Regierungsverantwortung übernommen haben
aber er wäre sowieso aber auch da ja
aber noch einmal jetzt gibt der gibt's
neue Verhältnisse aber auch da wäre sie
denkbar da wir auch mit der
afghanischen Führung darüber verhandeln
wie mit den ortskräften vor Ort noch
umgegangen wird dass man vielleicht
dafür Sorge tragen kann dass eine
Rückführung möglich wird wenn keine
Todesstrafe und Menschen über die
Bedingungen Afghanistan jeweils für
diese Person dann vorherrschen also ich
werde etwas pragmatischer als wir es
gegenüber ändern wir stoßen definitiv
unsere Leistungsgrenzen innerhalb
unserer Gesellschaft wir können die
Vielzahl von Menschen die zu uns kommen
auch schon gegengewärtig auch aktuell
jetzt zu uns kommen nicht mehr sinnvoll
integrieren wird das Gewaltproblem dass
wir aktuell haben zum Beispiel mit Blick
auf messertaten zum Beispiel mit Blick
auf schwere Straftaten
Körperverletzungen Vergewaltigung von
Frauen dass wir dieses Gewaltproblem an
unseren Grenzen lösen
es wäre sehr schön wenn wir das könnten
wir können es aber nicht wie gesagt weil
jeder der europäischen Boden betritt ein
Anspruch darauf hat dass er einem
rechtschreiblich Verfahren unterworfen
wird und dann eine bestimmte Zeit auch
hier ist wir müssten konsequenterweise
diejenigen die keinen Bleiberecht haben
weil wieder sie wieder Kriegsflüchtlinge
sind noch einer Syrien gegeben ist
konsequent rückgefühlt werden denn
ansonsten wird das ganze System der
Kontrolle sich ins wird absolet und sich
ins Gegenteil Verkehr das Gespräch mit
ihnen ist fast der illusionieren der sie
sagen jetzt seit einer Viertelstunde was
wir leider alles nicht können können wir
nur Obergrenze schaffen eine neue
Obergrenze die funktioniert wir haben so
viel illegale Einwanderung wie seit
sechs Jahren nicht in Deutschland das
könnten wir nur wenn wir das
schenkensystem aufheben würden
eigentlich kann ja niemand nach den
Regeln die Europa haben Deutschland
erreichen außer
also stürzt sich aus dem Flugzeug denn
wir sind ja nur von Ländern umgeben bei
denen Asylbewerber oder Flüchtlinge
zuerst ankommen und dort aufgenommen
werden müssten es sei denn wir haben ein
europäischen Partei Schlüssel an die
sich momentan auch leider keiner hält
das Problem könnten wir nur lösen wenn
wir das Schenken sie im Aufführung
wieder Außengrenzen schaffen das heißt
die Grenzkontrollen wieder einführen
auch dann gebe es mit Sicherheit
Möglichkeiten Menschen zu uns zu
schleusen aber durch deutlich geringerer
Zahlen entscheidend ist für mich das in
den letzten Jahren die lernerfahrer
gemacht worden ist wer einmal
Deutschland erreicht kann immer hier
bleiben und das ist eine Missachtung
unserer Rechtsordnung wer seine
Identität nicht preisgeben will wer
seine Pässe wegwirft wäre seine wahren
die verschleiert der hat sein
Bleiberecht im Prinzip damit schon
verwirkt und muss Konsequenzen sich ein
Stück weit in diesem Gespräch auch dem
hilflos hin
ja es gibt Dinge die kann ich
bedauerlicherweise nicht ändern genauso
wenig wie sie und die die Illusion wir
stellen jetzt den Grenzschutz wieder
flächendeckend auf dass die bayerische
Grenze in Richtung Süden Richtung
Österreich Richtung Tschechien ist so
immens dass selbst unsere ganzen
Sicherheitskräfte wenn wir sie in einem
Meter Abstand hinstellen würden nicht
ausreichen würden um die Grenzen
entsprechend zu schützen also eine
hundertprozentige sicheren Garantie gibt
es nicht aber es gibt die Notwendigkeit
unsere Rechtsordnung zumindest
durchzusetzen und nicht nach sich zu
üben niemand ist damit geholfen wenn wir
glauben wenn Leute und straffällig
werden müssen wir das damit
entschuldigen dass sie auch schlechten
Verhältnissen rauskommen das hilft nicht
weiter sondern ich teile noch einmal die
Auffassung von von Masur der gesagt hat
von Anfang an muss konsequent deutlich
gemacht werden wer diese Rechtsordnung
missachtet richtig volle Breitseite des
Rechtsstaat zu spüren
wir haben eine Reaktion von der
Innenministerin gelesen bei Twitter
unter dem Eindruck dieser schweren
Straftat von Brokstedt in
Schleswig-Holstein und dieser so aus ich
weiß nicht wie viel Empathie Herr
Kubicki sie daraus lesen es sind würde
ich sagen sehr floskelhafte Worte von
Betroffenheit einer Innenministerin ich
bedauerieren kann aber vielleicht sagen
Sie mir weil das da steht die Sätze die
Politiker in solchen Momenten sagen sie
zeigen sich betroffen und gehen dann zu
Tagesordnung über kann diese Tat von
Bruch steht diesmal etwas mehr sein und
tatsächlich die Politik verändern
eine realistische Antwort ja mit nein es
wird weitergehen wir nach jedem Unfall
zeigen die Betroffen mal nach jeder Tat
und davon hatten wir reichlich in der
Vergangenheit zeigen die Betroffenheit
die spannende Frage sind wir was kann
man tun und zwar unter unserer
rechtsstaatlichen Ordnung wir können
Menschen die ausreisepflichtig sind
gelegentlich auch in Ausreise haften
nehmen wo wir dann ein riesen Streit
bekommen nicht nur in unserer Koalition
sondern insgesamt ist das menschliches
das zutrennen kann man Menschen
einschweren die Ausreisepflicht sind
aber nicht ausreisen wollen
ich glaube es an der Zeit wenn wir nicht
erleben wollen dass die nachnahmeeffekte
von solchen Taten zunehmen werden denn
man muss wissen Menschen die zu uns
kommen und ihre Hoffnung Erwartungen
erfüllt sehen und dann zu solchen Taten
neigen wenn die nicht ordentlich
sanktioniert werden finden sehr schnell
Nachnahme weil man dann bekannt wird
berühmt wird jedenfalls ein Teil sein
selbst das Gefühl vielleicht wieder
aufbauen können wir müssen konsequent
werden und dazu gehört noch einmal dass
wir versuchen möglichst zu verhindern
dass mehr als eine bestimmte Anzahl von
Personen pro Jahr zu uns kommt
durch Überzeugung notfalls auch im
Rahmen der europäischen Einigung
notfalls auch indem wir auch da gibt's
ja Vorschläge aus Skandinavien die ja
nicht die Länder sind ja nicht dafür
bekannt dass sie sehr abweisend waren
die sagen in verschiedenen Bereichen
müssen wir zusehen dass unmittelbar nach
der Grenze die Asylverfahren bereits
offensichtlich keine aus ihrer Erfolg
eine solche Verfahrens hat der kann
nicht weiter nach Europa durchgelassen
werden das bedeutet dann eben
Auffanglager
auffangeinrichtungen in Griechenland in
Italien in Spanien dann müssen wir den
Menschen dort vor Ort auch helfen weil
die ja dann besonders belastet sind aber
anders werden wir es nicht schaffen und
vielleicht auch mal wenn das dänische
Modell tatsächlich erfolgreich sein
sollte mit Staaten in anderen Ländern
von denen wir davon ausgehen können Sie
achten die Menschenrechte versuchen
Rückführungsabkommen zu schließen weil
ich glaube jemand der von Palästina nach
Deutschland will und in Ruanda landet
dann irgendwann nach Palästina
zurückkehren wird das ist der ganz
kleine Funken Hoffnung an einem Tag der
sonst ja sehr viel Wut und sehr viel
Verzweiflung sehr viel Hilflosigkeit
auch mit sich gebracht hat und sehr
ehrliches Gespräch darüber mit dem
Bundestag viel zu Präsidenten Wolfgang
Bild danke Ihnen